you are known these days as a very
successful content creator and business
owner but um where did Sean Kel actually
start have you always been like this
partying uh hardcore you know chase
girls uh smoke weed I don't want to go
to college I don't want to do anything I
have no vision I don't have any
Ambitions at this point I have like no
dreams and in the light bulb moment I
also am like this party life is not that
cool it was during that time that my mom
and stepdad said uh what if you uh
propose the idea to Sea about going to
Prairie Bible College I called my mom
and I was like hey is there like a
chance to get involved in like the youth
ministry of this new church you guys
found and that is when that's when I got
into
video in today's episode we're going to
be sharing um things I don't think
you've really actually shared anywhere
Sean a lot of this is something that we
don't often talk about and so I am
really excited to get into this um you
are known these days as a very
successful content creator and business
owner you um run an eight figure
business you're a family man and
personally I know you as somebody who is
just incredibly wise and steady and just
dedicated to um growth in so many ways
and and dedicated to your work and so I
see you this way and I know that our
audience sees you this way but um where
did Sean actually start have you always
been like this yeah well I appreciate
your kind words and I just turned 40 so
the Journey's been wild you know but um
I definitely have not always been like
this and sometimes I feel like maybe the
image that's portrayed on social media
while true to today it's it's just so
different because I've really gone
through a lot of transformation um I had
an a great childhood grateful for my
parents but really some aspects of a
rough childhood um my parents got
divorced when I was was three so that
was uh a very intense season U my mom
kind of because of some kind of verbal
abuse some uh drug abuse by my
biological father and her fearing for
her own in my safety as well as just it
not being a very good environment uh
left my dad and was a single mom working
to support us and I remember we were
living in Edmund's Washington in a
basement of someone's house that rented
we rented out like a kind of a room of
someone's house or a a mother-in-law
kind of thing while I was very young
that was a very intense season and a few
years later she met my stepdad who's an
amazing man so grateful for both of my
fathers uh who are both living still and
uh but she met him and and really did
want to be rescued naturally um she was
looking and he was uh driving a Porsche
and she was working at a hospital and
food services and he was you know
wearing a suit and she saw this
successful businessman and he took note
of her and So eventually they got
married but what she didn't realize was
that he was going through a a very tough
divorce and there was all kind of
financial conflict from his exwife and
all this different stuff and credit
cards that have been ran up and that his
business was actually uh had a ton of
debt and a ton of issues even from that
divorce from other things that have
happened in the economy he had a glove
compartment full of speeding tickets and
his Porsche that was kind of his Vibe
and his attitude you know um and so they
got married and so I grew up kind of in
the Seattle region and then by I think
first second grade we moved to Arlington
Washington to six acres a little bit
more Rural and so um I would say you
know we were blessed kind of a a middle
class family and certainly was never
going hungry or anything but we
definitely were going through some
Financial challenges they were going
through a lot of marital challenges
fighting um my mom was always like a a
person of prayer she's a big woman of
Faith but kind of we're attending church
but I just remember growing up in an
environment with usually a lot of
fighting got to observe workaholism and
my dad uh you know he just loves work
and I inherited my stepdad and I
inherited probably a lot from that um
and uh I think that was actually pretty
good inheritance on the one hand like uh
one of the things that I think about is
there's a book from Robert kosaki called
Rich Dad Poor Dad and um I feel blessed
because of my My Two Dads uh my dad and
stepdad um that I I thought maybe I
could write a book called like creative
dad hardcore dad because before I want
to say that my uh stepdad and Mom got
married around eight or nine or
something like that and I I kind of
remember like I was this spoiled brat I
my mom I didn't have that male influence
or that strong male influence and I kind
of had a softness and also kind of like
this attitude and so one of the cool
things I inherited from my biological
father is he was an artist creative uh
Carpenter he was always in music cool
music all that stuff that's kind of
rubbed off on me that like like even
style culture in a city kind of like
Coffee Culture kind of hipster
independent culture kind of rebellious
kind of you know uh that I got to inher
that from my dad but throughout his life
he's been a starving artist like he's
always struggled financially um you know
I'd have to process some things cuz at
times he wasn't really doing child
support or whatever which made it even
harder on my mom so as I met my stepdad
he was kind of the opposite he really
was a provider climbing out of debt but
was a business Builder
entrepreneur um he's so been transformed
now and is so soft and and sweet and um
just an incredible grandfather to our
two boys but at the time he's was pretty
intense and while even a little bit
maybe tra traumatic as a child for me it
actually just kind of leveled me out
with that opposite extreme and I
sometimes see that the weakness of
creatives is they they love the art and
the creative but they lack kind of like
the discipline and the intensity and the
focus and the practicality that real
artists Don't Starve like you need that
entrepreneur side so when I think about
like the ingredients that kind of shaped
who I was today uh that was a little bit
of of my childhood and because of some
different trauma and even some exposure
to uh like pornography at a very early
age from like my dad's you know porn
collection um I remember I started
drawing some pictures and in sixth grade
I got they got discovered by my teacher
and it turned into this huge scene and
it went to actually court and visitation
started we started going through a bunch
of Vis visitation stuff and then my mom
was of course triggered again as she
should be and so there was a big season
where my dad definitely leveled out my
biological father um but where I didn't
see him for a couple years while we were
working that out because of the way like
the court ruling was on everything um
and so that was sort of those those
early like childhood teenage years and
as a result I was pretty angsty you know
you know uh and I know maybe a lot of
teenagers are but I think you know
started to really resonate with with
angsty music or you know angry teenager
and sometimes maybe that's how teens are
but there was definitely a lot of pain
and just trauma and trying to process
issues and divorce and seeing my stepdad
and Mom's marriage and the whole thing
and you know the way I look back of
course I I always I look through a lens
of gratitude and appreciation cuz I feel
like our parents are always doing the
best they have with what they have but
no doubt about it it was a really bumpy
road in my childhood yeah well we can
definitely see the influence of like you
said those those two um father figures
the creative dad and the hardcore dad um
definitely see that in you today but I
think that there's all those elements
like you mentioned of just how difficult
like going through those processes are
as that young kid and um I think seeing
you today I know that you are somebody
who really puts intention into
processing um what is happening around
you and I I think that is likely
something that's come out of that past
of you know just having experienced so
much at a young age and that's something
that I don't think that I ever even
realized how intense that that childhood
uh time was for you so as you moved into
your teenage years how do you think that
that kind of affected you come becoming
an a an adult becoming a teenager yeah
so we're in that now I guess we moved to
Arlington Washington and was going to
Arlington High School by my freshman
year and I remember my mom
was very worried about me and she should
have been um because maybe the the
culture at the school of course you
could find different friend groups and
whatnot I was never really plugged into
like uh again we were kind of a church
attending family but kind of just
culturally my mom's always been like
again a personal prayer and her faith
has been strong for her but as far as a
peer group I really didn't have like a
strong friend group and I started to get
into uh the culture of at least the
friends I was around where it was pretty
intense drugs and maybe just getting
started freshman year I look back now
and a lot of the people I went to high
school some are dead some got into
really hardcore drugs lost their mind um
and in Arlington Washington some of
these areas of course are changing and
growing and there's another area called
Granite Falls Granite Falls was kind of
known for um like crack and uh culture
and this kind of thing and and uh never
touched that but like was just different
places you could get around a lot of
people you know these days like
marijuana's legalized places and whatnot
but it's certainly was it then and you
know people's parents would be like
growing weed there' be some uh you know
um like a camper in the back yard that
you'd go over and someone's got this you
know six foot bong or something and so
these are like these are kind of the
people I was around and and I started
get into skateboard culture with some of
that comes along with that Absolut and
and love that whole scene snowboarding
underground rap uh hip hop Indie music
grunge Seattle right so that was kind of
freshman year but my mom was worried as
she should be and so she
was um very protective um the only way I
could get away with uh the levels of
Mischief that I did was by lying and
you'd go to your friend's house it's
hilarious too right because there was no
cell phones like there's no cell phones
there's your parents didn't know where
you were you're like I'm going to
Jordan's house um yeah we're just going
to like play video games and chill there
cuz he was the friend whose parents
would like let you disappear all night
and that was the bridge to Mischief but
the thing that was interesting was
because of of the levels of boundaries
and things she tried to put in place it
did keep me from absolutely getting
sucked crazy into some stuff at least at
first and so then as I as I transitioned
into my sophomore year my both parents
stepdad and Mom had been building up the
business kind of getting out of debt
money's a little bit better now and I
turned 16 so I could get my license and
drive and so I I'll never forget I got
my license on my 16th birthday I was at
the DMV at right as it opened to get my
driver's license I was blessed to be um
to get a Mazda
MX6 1990 or something and I worked all
summer when I was 15 to 16 to to earn
about $1,000 maybe $1,300 to buy two
12in subs a banp pass box a 600 watt RMS
amp um and I got my license drove the
car with the speakers to my friend's
house installed everything and that
night went to Regal Cinemas in Maryville
Washington real slow driving in front bo
bo bo window down is anybody looking no
one's looking what up I'm here in my
Mazda MX6 like we're doing this thing
and so I was so pumped cultures changed
so much like jenz doesn't even want
their license they're like we got Uber
like why would we drive so um but I got
uh so that was freshman year and as soon
as I got my license as we were going
into sophomore year my mom was like hey
would you want to go to Christian High
School would you want to go to Kings
High School which is also College Prep
Shoreline Washington and we were living
in Arlington so I started to commute
sophomore year I transitioned schools
and I started to
commute um about 45 minutes to an hour a
day as a
16-year-old um sometimes I would commute
with Lisa pson we would use carpool lane
but if I drove by myself I didn't have
car poool it was a gnarly drive he I was
just going to ask are you at this time
did you were you going to church do you
identify as a Christian or you're just
going you're just a wild teenager
heading off to Christian School to yeah
so I I I probably would identify like
hey what would be your heritage or what
is your belief I would probably say I
was a Christian but no I wasn't I wasn't
seeking god um or being a Christian we
were going to a church in in Marysville
and living in Arlington and we uh I was
like serving on the parking team but a
lot of times I'd be hanging out with
like my friend Aaron and we'd be talking
about how like you know how high we got
the night before or something and
whatever and and like and and you kind
of just were in you know that that's
that was the vibe that was this the
scene and so interestingly enough too
was again my mom's goal was like man if
I send him to King's High School a
Christian School a college prep school
he won't get in trouble there it's
probably just a bunch of saints and
Angels just trying to keep you
controlled kind of trying to keep you
controlled not realizing that actually
Christian Schools might be worse than
other schools in a lot of ways and uh
that actually turned out to be the case
not as an overarching thing I have deep
respect for kings and how powerful and
so many teachers but you can you can get
yourself into trouble anyways you just
got to find the right people and so uh
yeah I started to commute to high school
wow and so we saw the first glimpses of
the Sean kennel work ethic there working
towards your Mazda right so that was the
the goal oriented um work ethic but then
you you have your Mazda you've got your
cool car you've got you're kind of
getting into the skater scene and then
mom is trying to prevent anything really
bad from happening sending you off to
Kings exactly and and I actually I feel
like sophomore year I remember um I
dated a girl named Emily and it was a
pretty you know sweet wholesome
relationship and met my friend Chad
Twigs which was a crazy we had met early
on in Kings uh daycare or preschool and
so kind of met started to get into
things we we always played Sports I was
terrible at sports but I had I played
basketball for um a year horrible played
football for like two years was the
worst at it uh did track terrible at it
and actually as I started to shift into
uh ski bus and snowboarding that was
that's probably to this day did
snowboarding ski bus for maybe eight
years and so love snowboarding but
eventually um I I started to just really
get into uh you know partying uh
hardcore especially by uh junior year
while you're at Kings Christian college
or Christian High School Christian
School
and and really into Mr Morris I believe
my health teacher I remember he sat me
down once because I got had a reputation
with women started to get into like uh
dating or I mean it's high school so
sometimes it's kind you know kind of
like one hookup culture a little bit uh
can be and so I think you know maybe I
lost my virginity like sophomore a year
junior year or something and and then
started to um you know chase girls uh
smoke weed um and I got a eventually got
a Honda Civic and fasten the Furious
like I think about it was it was teal
maybe we could put a picture on the
video podcast it was teal green yellow
trim and then I remember I worked on
that one we did yellow trim on the dash
short shifter pedals intake header
change the exhaust up system green
ground lighting kit LED lights under the
dashb this thing looked like a Tesla
before Tesla existed all the little you
know I was LED lamps fog lamps um and it
wasn't even that fast but that was a
culture I remember I met my friend
Anthony Jesse who just came to my 40th
birthday party so when I think about
some of the people I've known the
longest Spencer Hurst who uh was also
there that was sophomore year at Kings
was when we we met you know the homies
and Anthony was actually dating someone
from Kings and so he was a Maryville guy
he had an eclipse kind of got into that
call Car culture there's an event called
Hot Import Nights or um in Seattle so I
was in import cars a hip hop you know
and this thing I think was I got a
custom license plate and I said DJ Blaze
no and uh you know DJ Blaze really said
DJ Blaze was the was the custom license
plate and I I actually traveled to visit
my cousin Adam and I went with my my
cousin Jillian to Southern California
this was a few years earlier but I just
think about how influential this trip
was so Adam was this cool Surfer Helen
uh his cousin was this pun punk rock uh
blue hair mohawk um I don't know if she
had tattoos then but she's a tattoo
artist now and um and I was in Arlington
I never felt like I fed in in the small
town I I love growing up on six acres
growing up with goats and horses and all
this kind of stuff but I wanted I wanted
like Southern California I wanted you
know skateboarding and um you know
underground hipop West Coast hip hop
whatever and so I remember we went to
like swap meets and we were skating Vari
old ditches and I bought on that trip
the wuang forever album when it dropped
I remember like going to a local Sam
goody or you know and uh I remember I
got the wuang album so when I think
about the mamore line that says like
that's what you get when wuang raised
you and and so I'm like I could actually
relate to that like I think probably a
lot of maore I was like yeah listening
to Wu Tang and so the DJ Blaze thing MC
Method Man was one of my heroes you got
to choose Your Heroes carefully that's
probably me and so I was uh just kind of
like and Method Man and red man were
just known for just like always like
smoking so much weed so I was always
trying to like get my hands on weed
always never getting caught and so you
know trying to trying to hide the smell
or whatever and and so anyways as that
that's kind of sophomore and junior year
and so as a result though um what it
things just continue to escalate um and
eventually there was multiple parties
parties at different people's houses my
friend Mitchell me had a lake house and
we it some crazy things happened there
including um eventually some things
leading up to me getting expelled right
before my senior year so I went to
King's sophomore and junior year and
then right before my senior year like a
few weeks I think before school started
I got expelled it was very traumatic for
me 100% of course my fault and deserved
but it was very you know kind of Shame
like you feel ashamed you thought that
you would walk and graduate I never have
I've never walked down and grad
graduated anywhere or like got a diploma
and the reason why was actually because
during one insane party I actually ended
up in a pornographic video with like
three other girls so that's insane yeah
um and I I'm pretty sure it was deleted
I sure hope so if it wasn't I guess it
might leak or something like Kim K and I
don't that's awful but uh you know like
pretty pretty wild and and what had
happened was the school talked to my
parent they're like we got word that
this happened that Sean's been partying
like crazy that he's a male jiggalo that
he's awful you know we he he's violating
all of our school's property at a
policies at a level that we have to to
to uh you know kick him out and that was
of course Very deserved so it kind of
sent me down even like a darker spiral I
kind of doubled down on darkness in a
way went to Everett Community College to
finish out high school and like I said I
never walked I got a Washington state
diploma from doing running start courses
at a local community college a little
bit closer to where I lived but that
year was just you know I mean I'm at the
time you might say like Life's good I'm
having fun I'm just partying getting to
kind of do what I want uh but I think
deep down I was just kind of sad you
know kind of numbing the pain smoking
weed every day taking some classes that
I didn't care about I never really
resonated with school I definitely know
that I'm an entrepreneur because
tradition the traditional box I also
think I always wanted out of that like
I'm sitting in class like why am I
taking math that I'm not going to use
might might have been the wrong
conclusion because math is certainly
helpful uh Mel knows math but uh and
ultimately but uh uh yeah so that's kind
of where I was at and and then things
really a turning point was coming up in
my life but that was some of the things
that had happened you know in in high
school and that just it was pretty
traumatic yeah that's wild I would never
picture that wild Sean knowing who I
know today how many years later you know
20 years later it's has you've changed
so much but that is a a very wild past
and I do wonder you know through those
high school years you know what would
you say to your younger self I know that
um there's probably many things but what
would you say looking back at that yeah
you know I would actually say as I look
back I think I think I would really
encourage people to avoid drugs M um and
and and for somebody I think like
universally a lot of people would agree
with that I know for some they're like
oh you got to sew your Wild Oats and
whatnot I know from a from like a
Christian perspective of course that's
the conclusion but I just think um man
it would have been so different if if I
just didn't get into they call things
gateway drugs it's true it's cuz it's
maybe in and of the thing it might seem
harmless or just like one night but then
it's it's what's that lead to next okay
now I'm going to go a little bit harder
the next time now your judge your
judgment's a little bit more impaired I
mean I also look back we're talking I
did a lot of dangerous things nights
where I blacked out for didn't have any
memory of what happened nights when we
absolutely should not have been driving
nights on 4:20 having just smoking weed
all day getting pulled over by the cops
somehow getting out of this situation
but like just all these different things
and you think about like I'm like I
should be dead or I could be injured and
I could have somebody else so I think
there is something about like picking
the right friend group there is
something about I also I think dealing
with trauma I think I would also look
back because a lot of times what we we
turn to those things yes maybe to have
fun but it also turns into a to numb the
pain yeah so I don't know if if as like
a teenager you could just be like hey
Mom I want to go to counseling and I
would have even had but like I think if
there was some things and I I really do
wish I was planted in a church Community
where you're having prayer and community
and all those kind of things that was my
option and that I could see it being
entirely different that's my plan for my
kids I don't know what's going to happen
with sha Bradley and John Steven of
course there's you know they're
individuals but to take the lessons I've
learned and to really encourage them and
what I also think is different is um you
know people say do you regret well yeah
I've done some regretful things and I
would definitely have would change those
if I could but I also think that
mistakes and even challenges that we get
through in life they they do turn us
into who we are today so if you view it
kind of through this lens of Grace
there's they definitely shape us but um
when I look at some of like just on an
entrepreneurial side some people that
didn't touch drugs that stayed in sports
and took it seriously that focused on
their learning and maybe I
also I wouldn't say the school system
failed me but maybe it kind of did
because I think we need Educators and we
need leaders and we need people to
identify the proclivities maybe some of
the adhd's or the assess ofen I think
I've got some OCD stuff you know what
are train a child in the way they should
go and when they're old they won't
depart from it like what way should they
go I think again the 12 years of middle
school and high school and Elementary
School I don't fit there that might
that's that's not what we're going to do
with our kids H School World School
tutoring and more maybe entrepreneurial
like let's just get you into something
let's get your creativity working let's
get you you know there was a little
glimmer of what was H one of my favorite
classes at Kings was I was a part of the
uh radio station there was a a
crossrock radio station and I started to
use Adobe Audition in high school mixing
the the talking portion and music
Transitions and so not only did I start
seeing some glimmers of of my uh maybe
unique unique talents and passions um
but that that also I was pumped about
that and less pumped over here so I
think you you definitely got to
experiment and find your thing but those
are some things that I look back and
just think man um I definitely would
would do some things different but
grateful because all of the ups and
downs and life's complex have made me
who I am today and I think I view
through a Jesus lens God really does
work all things to the good of those who
love him and are called according to his
purpose and you know can unpack a little
bit more of that later but that's what I
hoped you know to kind of view my whole
child Ood through yeah well you
certainly had God's hand on you that
that you're even here today based on
even like more details of those stories
I know like of the wild things that have
happened so I'm grateful that you're
here and um he take us into what
happened next to again help get you to
the Manu today yeah so I if this it kind
of feels like this was kind of a a
continuous downward trajectory because
now I'm at every ever Community College
running start and mainly focusing on
just finishing high school and partying
like my goal in life is is kind of like
a hip-hop song and to this day I I still
love hip-hop music still listen to you
know different stuff but I am thoughtful
because the what are the me what is the
message and so I share some stuff in my
stories and whatnot because uh I think
Hip Hop is an incredible art form I was
by the way in the high school talent
show uh at Kings I did uh I wrapped for
the high talent show it's ridiculous but
I was you know always into freestyl
where the tape of that that's what we
want to see a great question um and so
yeah so I always was like you kind of
really into but in a way I that was sort
of what I was shooting for you know I'm
driving around listening to Eminem
hoping that this girl text me back or
something you know smoking a blunt like
that's kind of just was like what it was
and I was I think I was kind of getting
just more into I wasn't happy you know
maybe a difference between surface
happiness or euphoria that could be
induced by drugs or experiences or CH
chasing dopamine or whatever but so so
that year that was kind of everything I
was doing and then I started to get into
like some harder core Rave drugs started
to get into the Rave scene always loved
EDM and so ecstasy mushrooms and that
led to probably the most pivotal night
that I could call maybe somewhat of a
rock bottom that thing started to shift
and so had a girlfriend at the time
named Andrea and we went to this raven
Seattle with I think my friend Jesse and
Brian and maybe a few other people but
leading up to that event I think I had
like 4 days off work I'm waiting tables
at Red Robin I'm 17 or
18 and that's how I'm paying the bills
making some tip money snowboarding when
I can also like part-time do an espresso
stand up at uh Stevens's pass to get a
free pass no time to actually snowboard
Because by the time I waited tables did
the espresso job and partied I never
snowboarded that year but I that was my
dream but I was overcrowded with my
ambitions I think and so we went to this
Rave but the day before I remember we
were just hanging out like partying and
uh my friend Jesse I think warned me cuz
I was like let's just get lit now and
and uh she's like no you know you can't
you shouldn't take ecstasy two days in a
row because when you take it all your
serotonin is released that's like the
crazy Euphoria but then you you need to
replenish it I was like whatever you
know r or die you know whatever so I
took like an eighth of mushrooms and
like two ecstasy pills or something
that's called hippie flipping and
that's that was insane and then got up
so that was like night one and then we
went to this Rave so you're kind I'm in
a depleted State probably dehydrated you
know probably some things like that we
go to this Rave and so then what also
happens you just have to take more and
more and more so I think I took like one
two or three ecstasy pills or whatever
and my friend Brian was a dealer and he
we were at this rave but he he popped
like six pills or something and he
disappeared uh got lost we didn't know
where he was we had cell phones by this
time noia brick phones custom face PLT
blinky light on the top you know snake
you know what it is it's my favorite
game I have the same phone number since
high school um and so if anybody wants
to text me I'm still same
number um and so so he gets lost I at
this point now the Ecstasy is
ineffective all all that's working is
just the speed aspect whatever it's cut
with so you're kind of just taking
taking speed so so we're up all night
but I also remember that night I almost
like it was a pretty Supernatural
experience I remember almost feeling cuz
I one thing that was very interesting
was my mom was always praying for me she
she knew what I was doing my stepdad
kind of knew what I was doing they
didn't maybe me know the extent but I
remember my night it was almost like my
eyes were open to like this spiritual
realm and I actually started to like see
demons and how they were interacting
with with people at this Brave and and I
that's dark and scary and so I'm there
but I my heart is kind of wrestling and
I think my mom was praying for me this
whole time you know shows you prayer is
real the power of prayer um up praying
at night she would do what's called like
night prayer watches for me and just
always was had this vision of my son you
know will uh well this was not his
future this is not where what he'll be
doing and so anyways we're up all night
as you do because you couldn't go to
sleep with all the drugs
and I remember when the sun started to
rise the next morning skyline of Seattle
um and people like Mayhem everywhere
kind of the outdoor of wherever the Rave
was called Candyland and and the morning
after a rave is awful because everyone's
coming down you know headaches hung
over uh it's pretty sad also like
everyone looked good in kind of the dark
flashy lights but now when the the light
is you're like H like
you look eyes are all make bloodshot are
yellow and oh you're tired like it's
it's a dark scene and not only that
you're also like you're coming down off
of drugs and you're tired or whatever
not a lot of Joy that's happening in
that moment but to make matters worse
Andrea my girlfriend and I are just kind
of walking through the Carnage of all
these people around us that are just
kind of recovering and we have no ride
home we don't know where Brian our ride
is he's been lost all night and it's
kind of like this You Know Drama amongst
us like where's Brian what are we going
to do where's Jesse and so we end up
just getting in a stranger's car they're
like come with us so we hop in a
stranger's car I have to work this day
at Red
Robin clearly this was not a very good
planning on my part right and so sun's
coming up we get in some strangers car
we drive to Edmond's Washington which
for anybody listening it's like it's a
very conservative chill that's where my
grandparents who had a dental office had
a house
very
Northwest uh you know this wasn't like
the streets of Miami or even the streets
of Seattle it's Edmonds Washington we
just go to some random house and this
was so insane we go to this random house
and there is a party that is just
getting started it is like 7 a.m.
Sunrise party and it sort of is also
kind of like do you have no shame you
know sort of because it's not like
middle of the night like whatever it's
just like the morning like this is
breakfast like you're doing drugs for
breakfast like so anyways we walk into
this party we don't know anybody and I
sit down kind of still Gathering my
thoughts you know I I don't feel great
sitting next to my girlfriend I start
looking around and I realize like
there's handguns on the table cocaine
blunts
weed subwoofers gangbangers and a
variety of all kinds of people around me
are just partying getting lit taking
shots I'm actually now getting pretty
clear-headed because I'm not touching
any of that stuff and I'm sitting there
and I will never forget I have like an
epiphany and it's this I may have made
one or bad one or two bad decisions
leading up to this point like as I
observe just clicking in you're like the
like verifiable evidence that is
surrounding me the paraphernalia and the
evidence that's surrounded me and the
time of day and the uh the um you know
type of people and the whole thing that
I'm around I made one or two bad
decisions that led up to this point like
this didn't happen by accident and uh
and in a way almost like a light bulb
like there's a story in the Bible says
the prodical son it says when he came to
himself after after wild living and
spending his money and doing whatever so
I'm kind of coming to myself so I'm like
we got to go so I grab Andrea we just
start walking so we just start walking
the streets of Edmonds sun is like fully
out now and I just remember I'm like
sick to my stomach probably partly from
you know drug abuse but also just
because of like the life like I'm like
who even am I where am I going what am I
doing and I remember I I feel bad
because I I was I started I started to
break down and cry and I was kind of
like mad at her she didn't have anything
that I should have been mad at but like
why where are we I started just like
complaining and breaking down like
where's Brian like what are you doing
why are we here like I'm you know just
taking I'm just angry sad confused and
we get a call on the Nokia phone you
know and actually uh get picked up by
Jesse they found Brian Brian's in the
car and we go back to uh her apartment
and it's it's just we're all kind of
like this this has just been kind of a
dark time Brian was lost we thought he
was gone look at where we're all we are
now um I think that you know we light up
some weed which just to take the edge
off of the pain of you know all this
other stuff and then I'm I'm thinking to
myself like I got to go to Red Robin and
do a double shift I think I started
11:00 a.m. ever at Washington work till
like 11:11 a lot of times I do 12 hours
and good advice from my friends was like
you should probably calling sick but I
was like nah so I popped another ecstasy
pill not that it would make me crazy
just for the speed of it just like Jack
me up so I can actually go to work I go
to work I work the whole shift I
remember my co-workers they're like bro
you don't look good and I looked all
jaundice my whole skin turned yellow and
my eyes looked all weird so I persevered
through the shift went home finally I
had been gone for a couple nights went
home and went to sleep and all of that
partying and all of the emotions and all
of that fatigue caught up to me the next
morning I think I maybe had you know a
day or two off or I just started working
daily and and I went into maybe a weekl
long depression where I was like what
even is there there's just nothing what
what do we what you know and it was
during that time that my mom and
stepdad said uh it was my stepdad's idea
cuz he kind of had seen what was
happening in my life she'd been praying
and he's like hey Susan my mom what if
you uh propose the idea to Shawn about
going to Prairie Bible College which is
a small Bible College in Three Hills
Alberta Canada that is in the middle of
Arctic
tundra it's one or two hours away from
Calgary it's a super small town
surrounded by nothing usually snow and
there's only a thousand people in the
town 2,000 people go to this smaller
Bible school and the only reason we knew
about this place is because I have some
missionaries in my family and Pastors in
my family and my mom had gone there and
her brother Nelson and some other people
my cousin B uh Benjamin was there at
this moment he's going to be going back
for another year so my mom I think I was
like sweeping the back porch doing some
chores or something and she's like like
hey Sean like I was I was thinking you
know and had no Prospect ects I'm done
with I think ever at Community College I
don't want to go to college I don't want
to do anything I have no vision I don't
have any Ambitions at this point I have
like no dreams and in the light bul
moment I also am like I this party life
is not that cool like you know like or
look where I'm at like look what has
this really gotten me and even even
having maybe some things but things
don't satisfy so she goes what would you
think about going to Prairie and I
remember like I didn't really have to
think about it that long I was like yes
that's what I want to do and what
clicked in my mind was this
it wasn't like cuz I really wanted to go
to a Bible College it was actually
because I was like I'm in such a like
destitute place kind of emotionally
especially that I just need a radical
change I just need to do something
different and I know I need to get out
of these
circumstances the thing that in my mind
was I thought I was going to be a monk
meaning I thought rather than go
someplace where I could get into trouble
I that sounds actually kind of great to
just go someplace where I could sort of
clear my head and be dis connected it
wasn't as disconnected I cuz I assumed I
was like Prairie where there's no
electricity you know like that's kind of
what I thought you know I was like that
sounds cool and once I got there I was
like it's kind of the same as anything
you know but so I said yes and so I
remember uh eventually traveled to
Prairie um I got my wisdom teeth out and
we drove like 16 hours and I was like
painkillers and like a pillow in the
back seat and I got dropped off and my
parents dropped me off and um I'll never
forget because as soon as it set in like
immediately they leave I'm in my dorm
room and I'm like what was this decision
what am I now I'm in Three Hills Alberta
how did I get here like what did I
commit to and so I enrolled in what was
called a certificate of Bible I then
spent the next um year uh studying the
Old Testament and New Testament and
going through like these classes that
would lead to a certificate in Bible and
the first you know half of the year the
first two quarters
um before Christmas I was kind of good
started to okay I'm going to go to class
I'm going to be disciplined I'm going to
be good but guess what I found the same
people that you can find anywhere I
found a guy thank God cuz my my father
actually really struggled with cocaine I
think it would be a very very bad thing
for me I never touched it but I found a
found a friend up there who was he had
access somehow to all this cocaine and
he was he was do that stuff found other
access to drugs uh I'll never forget
because my parents I I do believe
they're paying for me to go here it's
not very expensive school they paid for
my meal card so I'd always eat only at
the cafeteria and then bringing my stuff
up I had my my living was fully
supported living on campus so I think
they gave me money to pay for anything
else I would need but I didn't need
anything else so it was like 200 bucks
for like six months and there was like a
little thrift store there for clothes so
that's $2 here $2 here and then it was
the laundry machine was coin based so
for sure that'd be plenty of money and
what was that first six months I
remember my cocaine friend was like yo
do you want to go into Calgary or
somewhere else like Red Deer go to a
club I'm like for sure and you got
drinking age there is 18 so um in Canada
or 19 and so we we go to this club and I
remember you know I bought like six
beers by the end of the night or
something but it cost me all $200 so I
spent all of my money in one night and I
was down to zero which again I could use
my mu card or whatever but again I was
like that was a that was bad stewardship
like Dave Ramsey would not have approved
of that budgeting in that situation so
anyways during that first six months um
again I kind of found the wrong friends
and still was trying to like find my way
and I'll never forget because I went
home for Christmas vacation and Darren
Troutman threw a party and uh I think I
was still kind of dating my like my
girlfriend Andrea she's there whatever
my friend Brian who got lost right
and so um oh before that I remember I
went home and I now I started thinking
okay I'm becoming a new man I'm I'm
studying the Bible now I'm On A New Path
I'm going to go home I'm excited to
visit my friends but I'm not going to
touch any of that stuff like I I just
want to hang with my friends it's going
to be cool and I remember we went to
Jesse's house and um and then the blunt
came out and so puff puff pass you got
it you know you're sitting in a circle
there's you know six of us or seven of
us there and I remember they're like
Sean's back cool and I'm sitting down
great start to pass the blend I remember
it came to me and I was like no I'm good
you know it's all cool I love hanging
out with you guys it's all good so pass
me came back around puff puff p no I'm
good pass me third time all right yo let
me hit that let's go you know because
and but hey principle I Learned was um I
I think that sometimes willpower is
overrated and we think like oh I'm just
going to be strong I think that you got
to set up your environment and you got
and especially if if your willpower is
on an extra weak side it's kind of like
if I have Reese's peanut butter cups in
my pantry I eat them if I don't have
reaches peanut butter cups in my pantry
I don't eat them so it's so environment
really matters and this actually really
led me to a major conclusion because not
only was it that but the the part the
year end party at Darren's house and the
next it was always the next morning for
me I was at work whatever the next
morning I think my dad stepdad Phil
would was going to drive me ac I think
it was across the border to Vancouver to
an airport or he drove me to Bellingham
probably the Bellingham Airport to take
a flight to Alberta Calgary or whatever
to get back to school so I need to be
meeting my stepdad at maybe like 9:00
a.m. or 10:00 a.m. in order for us to
get to the airport the next day for me
to go back to Bible College well here's
what happened the night before so we go
to this party and you know maybe some
negative peer pressure Brian's idea is
what if we do a fifth off now a fifth
off is where you drink a fifth in this
case of raspberry Schoff vodka as fast
as possible you take a shot I take a
shot how long does it take us until we
finish the whole bottle I think we did
it in seven minutes and we're like yeah
crushing it and that alcohol hit my
system so quickly absolutely impairing
my judgment already I probably couldn't
hold my liquor of of that but now I'm
like let's keep it going jello shots are
coming around boom boom and I don't even
know I black out pretty quick or at
least yeah my memory disappeared then I
remember I wake up I'm in a bathtub and
it's like 1: or 2 a.m. I am throwing up
like crazy Andre's trying to take care
of me like it's it's a dark place like
so um I I black out again you know um
and I wake up the next morning I got to
get back to Bible college but here's
what is happening I'm in like Darren
troutman's game room TV room and I like
wake up and I start looking around
headache pounding and I'm like shoot
like okay and I don't even know you know
what kind of what day it is or where
what I where I need to go or whatever
and then I like look down and I start
I'm like where are my pants like I have
boxers on but I'm like where where where
are my pants then I'm looking around
where's my phone can't find my phone I
like want to text my dad it's all good
going to be there soon so then I'm like
trying to ga myself gather my things I
walk to his window I look out into the
driveway where is my car so my car is
missing that I need to drive home I
can't find my phone I'm walking around
the house angry again and frustrated and
feeling the pressure at a high level so
I finally find my phone I I wake
somebody up where's my car and they're
like oh Skyler took it you took Andrea
home or whatever so I like I like I'm
like calling Skyler doesn't pick up
calling Skyler doesn't pick up bro what
do you want uh my car like I need my car
to get home so he's like oh sorry
whatever so he so he drives the car back
over I'm trying to you know get hydrated
or whatever and then I hop in my car
trying to also compose myself like
texting my dad all good just coming home
stayed at Darren's last night and I
remember my he looked at me when I got
there and again I probably looked a
little little tattered and uh he was
like you're you're ready to go and I was
like yep and we dropped jumped into his
Ford F-150 drove to the airport and I
went back to Bible College well the
reason I share all that was again once I
collected myself and it kind of helped
me learn too that maybe sometimes in
life we take three steps forward and
four steps back or you know three steps
forward but only two steps back so I'm
kind of making progress kind of studying
the Bible but still that was a pretty
bumpy Christmas season so when I got
back I started learning these lessons
like okay maybe um I should be
thoughtful about the I don't have very
strong go power clearly if I put myself
in a fifth off I'm going to do it like I
like challenges like if you challenge me
I'm going to you know if I put myself in
the circle where everyone's passing the
blunt like I don't have the willpower
and then when I got back my life started
to really shift even more just from
studying the Bible but from actually get
encountering a group of Christians that
I would say are like real Christians and
I wasn't not to judge anybody but
sometimes Christian Christianity can be
like more cultural but like people's
lifestone align with it m included maybe
when I'm attending church but when I met
some people who were like really like
they had like really encountered Jesus I
never forget Britney was one of them and
she was just so amazing and such an
influence in my life and she like re
like she was like really like valued my
interest over her own like really loved
others had also like real authentic Joy
I started to hang with people who would
Sam who uh I think eventually went into
Ministry and he'd play his acoustic
guitar we would like kind of like sing
and read the Bible and stuff but but I
was it was like real and I started to
just kind of be around really
experiencing love and acceptance in a
non-judgmental way cuz I still had all
these issues and I'm all cynical I'm
kind of really a mean person very
sarcastic at others expense and would
kind of cut people down and whatnot and
these guys just had this unlimited kind
of Grace and just welcoming me in and so
over the next six months my heart
started to shift even more and I'd say
soften even more and my I really started
to shift because because for studying
the Bible now Old Testament now New
Testament I really got exposed to the
gospel and I got exposed to like um
seeing I never really read the B been in
church but i' never really read or
studied the Bible and seeing that like
over hundreds and thousands of years
previous to Jesus there were predictions
prophecies made about him in explicit
detail that he perfectly fulfilled with
his life on earth and the details
recorded by eyewitnesses and I started
to learn about things like the
statistical probability of that
happening is absolutely impossible
there's no way apart from some
Supernatural element that that could
have happened so the foundations of
actually building my faith not just on a
fairy tale not just on you know a
feeling but building my faith on the
truth of God's word but also the history
and the the facts uh and recorded things
that we see about Jesus that started to
shift me then the environment started to
shift and so this is the big turning
point was as I knew I was going to go
back to um summer in Washington in
Maryville go back home live with my
parents and my plan was to go back to
Prairie for a second year because now
I'm like this is kind of the path I'm on
and they're like Britney and you know
Sam are you coming back next year like
yeah I mean I don't know what else I'm
doing like I'm still like I don't really
have Vision I this is what I want to do
with my life this is who I want to be
kind of just getting like in a way
healed you know sort of just um slowly
going through that emotional recovery
and coming to myself so I I make a plan
I'm like okay I know what happened last
Christmas um I need to do something
different hey we're about to get back
into the podc in just a second but I
have a question for you do you want to
grow your personal brand this year do
you need more leads and sales in your
business if the answer is yes then right
now is the best time to go all in on
YouTube today's podcast is brought to
you by think masterclass.com where you
can get on demand access to a 1hour deep
dive training revealing how to start and
grow a profitable YouTube channel this
year for a limited time you can get
access to this on demand class entirely
for free where you will learn the three
biggest mistakes that people make when
starting a YouTube channel the new rules
and changes that have been happening on
YouTube and how you can use them to
create an unfair advantage and the exact
back strategy we use at think media to
generate over
350,000 organic views every single day
the data is clear 70% of viewers claim
that YouTube makes them more aware of
new brands so don't wait any longer to
start growing your brand and business
with YouTube just go to think
masterclass.com to get access to this no
fluff highly tactical free on demand
training that's think masterclass.com
and I had studied the story of King
David who's this you know remarkable
historical figure Who Loved God so much
but also had some issues and one of
these verses about his life it says that
in the spring when kings go out to war
and he was the king he was pacing on his
balcony when he saw bath Sheba bathing
naked down below so he called her up
slept with her she's someone else's wife
she gets pregnant it sets up a whole
domino effect of drama so I learned this
powerful lesson that Idle Hands lead to
trouble quick that if you don't that
it's not enough that that willpower
thing like I'm just going to pray about
it and just hope I stay strong no you
got to be about something you got to you
got to put yourself in the right
environments and so knowing that I
thought okay I love my friends that are
back home I would love to you know still
see them and and uh but I also know that
they have a greater influence on me than
I probably have on them my willpower is
not that strong so here's what I'm going
to do I'm going to go back Red Robin
they know I'm coming back that's where
I'm going to make my money I'm going to
enroll in online classes for B Prairie
Bible Institute so I got to go home and
study and I'm going to intern at a
church why that's the only reason it
wasn't like I really want to build the
church the only reason was I called my
mom and I was like hey is there like a
chance to get involved in like the youth
ministry of this new church you guys
found previous to that they had been we
had grown up kind of in the Seeker
friendly kind of church you might call
it Seeker sensitive that's kind of a
whole side question of itself but the
fact that they' kind of shifted to a
church that was like similar to Sam and
Britney that like the real call it
powerful presence of God was active it
was kind of like you could call it
Revival in a way and also things like
just extreme s um generosity real
authentic prayer seeing like
Supernatural events happen and things so
my parents had discover this church
which is radical for them because in a
way they were kind of like almost anti-
charismatic Pentecostal but that had
sort of shifted I didn't know any of
this stuff all I knew was like I don't
want to get in trouble oh you guys are
going to a new church maybe I can
volunteer and so during the next
Christmas break I met Jeff Morris he had
just he has like three kids now that are
now getting into college uh and they
just had U maybe like their first
daughter and met him I was like hey I
would love to volunteer in the youth
ministry I remember him saying uh it was
him and David luster were co-running the
youth ministry and they met with me at
Starbucks and they told me later they
said man this guy has potential and he
probably has some skill sets but he is
arrogant like this guy is prideful like
he's got some work uh and I kind of I I
was cocky knowitall kind of vibe so
anyways they let me volunteer and and
that is when you know talk about YouTube
that's when I got into video so now it
wasn't that I was like I want to do
video um I want to this is my plan this
is my Vision I was kind of just more
responding in each season and by
choosing to volunteer at this church
which what's that meant that meant that
I gave up every Wednesday we would pray
at 7:00 a.m. from 700 to 8: and then we
would start printing Flyers planning for
youth group uh we' do a little
discipleship class the entire day and we
went from morning prayer all the way
until youth at night we would we would
um if we had you know our licenses or a
car we would you know pick kids up
uh around um the region take them home
after youth group so it was like this
long like 14 hour 16 hour day that's
what I was commited to and I just
committed I just was like that's what
I'm doing and when I committed
eventually Jeff handed me a video camera
and Adobe Premiere this is
2002 or three and I start editing weekly
video announcements for the Youth
Ministry it was a Canon hv30 you
captured minute for minute so if I
filmed like an hour of just absolute
Shenanigans and meaningless like
20-year-old you think you're funny and
you're not you know video I would then
have to plug it into this awful computer
capture it would take 60 Minutes to
capture the footage because it just
recorded it basically like capture card
onto the computer I would edit it and
then I would actually have to record it
back onto a mini DV tape from Adobe
Premiere put that into a VHS converter
put that into a VCR at the back of our
youth group sanctuary and that's how we
played the video announcements Wednesday
night on the screen that might sound so
archaic and in 2003 it was because
churches have like no money so we were
still probably like pretty far behind
but you want to talk about gratitude and
absolutely zero tolerance for any modern
content creator complaining the gray in
this beard is real man I'm like you're
talking you're complaining about your
iPhone 14 pro you're complain about your
highspeed SD cards and your Mac M1
editing footage what do you this is this
is where I I came from the streets like
I came from and so so anyways what's
Wild though is you talk about being a
content creator I made 52 videos that
year because I made one every single
week and then eventually the Senior
Pastor Mike was like you have a decent
level of skill even though your first
videos are your worst videos and
everything's way more impressive then I
mean if you compare now to then
he said how about you make videos for
the weekends as well so I now started
doing two videos a week 104 videos a
year and social media hadn't even
started so just also the blessing of
getting into um this muscle of learning
to create content learning to do video
and again people say did you just choose
video in some big strategy I feel like
video chose me I actually really believe
that if you're faithful with what's in
your hand God will give you what's in
your heart and I just was trying to show
up and put it in my hand was Adobe
premere and a camera and I just started
to use it and once I started to develop
some confidence and some competence at
video If you fast forward seven eight
years when think media started with
camera tips and tutorials that's where
it all started was it was just because I
had now been doing video and maybe there
was glimmers of that back when I was in
Cross rock radio doing Adobe Audition so
I just kept doubling down and so you
know before we go further I I I just
have it on my heart to share that you
know I think there's a big question I've
heard word some people say people don't
change and that's actually maybe
probably true if it's left up to us just
on our own but I remember hearing
there's a verse where Jesus says with
man this is impossible but With God all
things are
possible and now I think about all the
transformation I'd gone up into that
point and and talking about change now
that I'm planted in this youth group I'd
been there maybe one or two years and we
would do these things called encounter
overnights so it's a Friday night it's
like a mini conference we'd have like
one speaker some more music another
speaker and I'll never forget one of
those encounter overnights where I'm now
an intern maybe for a year or two this
is also when I met Becky Davidson who is
the wife of Kevin Davidson who I met at
Prairie Bible College and so he's you
know a Canadian now married to an
American living here in Las Vegas uh she
was the only other intern with me so
Becky and I go way back and then Kevin
we go all the way back to Prairie um her
and I are like the only interns and
we're doing this encounter overnight I'm
sitting in the seats and I remember as a
a pastor will usually speak and then
they give like an alter call and in this
case he was like hey come down to the
front um if you want to respond like you
know you need to get right with God you
know that you're far from God and you
get need to get right with God and I'll
never forget cuz I was sitting in the
chair and I started to experience
something that kind of felt strange and
it was it was this like
urge like this spiritual urge like I
have to go down front but I remember in
my mind I'm like I can't go I can't
respond to I'm one of the leaders like
what are the kids going to think if like
the the second or third in command to
Jeff and David the interns you know I'm
like I can't go down there like what is
that but I just it was just so real and
I started to think like it's not about
anybody else in the room it is literally
I felt like this call of God to go down
front so I I get the courage and I step
up and I walk down front and I remember
you know a few of us are maybe standing
there music's playing and the pastor
starts to pray for different people and
he prays for me I know people may maybe
have seen this different places and
there's different this idea of if
someone gets prayed for and they like
fall down or whatever and my mom would
be the one when I was growing up to be
like that's fake or people are pushing
people or all this kind of stuff and
that wasn't really the style of this
church at all but I remember I got
prayed for and what happened next was
absolutely insane I
it was like I was almost like struck by
lightning and I felt just extreme power
of God overwhelming my entire body head
to toe so I'm on the ground and I also
remember it felt like oceans of God's
love were just washing over my heart
over my mind felt like my history and
the pain and childhood and and my
parents and high school and the mistakes
I made and all the guilt I felt from the
people I had hurt and the people I had
wounded because of my bad decisions and
all of this stuff was like just being
washed away and I felt this incredible
love of God the Father for 45 minutes
Non-Stop and there's a revivalist named
Charles finny who would talk about
having you know that there's encounters
with God's love like waves of liquid
love and that's what it was and I
remember as like the night started to
transition
um they started talking to people hey
what are maybe what's been your
experience or what is something you
learned tonight you know fast forward to
today we say like what are your ahas
like what do we just like what what are
your ahas and I was like I remember
verifiably cuz my friends would say it I
had of course still a ton of issues and
stuff but I had been transformed into a
new man I had a encounter with God that
changed my heart and changed my mind and
here's what I realized it was also it
wasn't because of anything I had done it
wasn't because of self-will or
discipline or wasn't because it was
because of just God's goodness and just
the power of the gospel and the fact
that we serve a real and living God who
is living and active the power of his
word and those principles is so
important because i' had been studying
those but but there I I believe this it
has to kind of go beyond just the the
the the Bible there are people who teach
the Bible who are not Christians there
are people who teach the Bible who maybe
don't even really want to follow God or
they just they're just studying a book
and it's words on paper but those words
can come alive when the spirit of the
author of the book encounters you and um
I feel like in our world today of
self-help and personal development and
everyone is like let's go ice plunge and
let's just discipline ourselves and all
that kind of stuff and I'm into all that
kind of stuff but man there's something
more than that and that's not the gospel
the gospel is we can't earn it or
deserve it nor is it about even like
cleaning up our life or getting our life
right now it's simply about for God so
loved the world that he sent his one and
only son Jesus this historical figure
the hero of History who split history
literally the way we Track Time by this
historical event that is more than words
on a page or just some you know oral
tradition passed down it is a living
reality that's available to everybody
listening to this right now and that
sometimes I think it could feel like we
are so far from God but he is it says
the Kingdom of Heaven is at hand and I
would encourage people that the Bible
says if you seek him you'll find him if
you seek him with all your heart and and
maybe sometimes well what does that look
like I believe you know you could pray
right now or maybe you have a Bible in
your house you crack it open or maybe
someone's been inviting you to church or
there's a church you pass by in your
city and you've kind of felt I should
check that out or or or just exploring
on YouTube just beginning to maybe ask
questions and I know there's a lot of
questions that was helpful of me being
at Prairie it's called apologetics what
about the dinosaurs or what about this
and so I I had kind of been on that
track but this shifted everything man
when I encountered God they do say you
know it's like almost it's impossible to
talk
somebody uh out of their faith if
they've had an encounter you might be
able to reason someone out if all
they've got is like words on a page but
I can't I will never not be able to look
back at this moment and be like and and
and coming from the person who's done
enough drugs to know that I hadn't done
any and this was a
supernatural
extraordinary invasion of what we now
know is God's spirit that's living and
active on Earth and so anyways I want to
encourage I I think that this next year
could be people's best year if it's
their best year spiritually and I really
believe I mean the gospel is for
everyone it's available for for everyone
and to seek that out that we cannot save
ourselves we we are all of us have
fallen short of the glory of God we all
have made mistakes and errors and maybe
not crazy like me but uh maybe um it's
just it's our heart issues selfish lying
you know we all god is perfect and he
has a perfect standard and there's no
way we could reach that standard but he
sent his son to bridge that Gap and that
can change everything and and so for me
now I'm in church got the video camera
but now my heart is being transformed
and th that became the formation of the
next years of you know now kind of where
we are today making me who I am and then
it was through the next couple years in
particular one of the cool things about
this church was they were very um
entrepreneurial in the sense that they
they had a conference called like
Prosperity with the purpose and they
brought in um speakers that had built
construction businesses and whatnot and
I began to discover as people have maybe
heard me say I began to discover that in
addition to first and foremost the Bible
being the inspired word of God that it's
also the greatest success book ever
written and that actually all of these
principles in the Bible about call it
marketing business uh leadership
teamwork
relationships um of course personal
issues but also business money financial
management and so my Foundation of going
into three years of Bible College um
through I didn't go back to Prairie I
stayed at turning point that a local
Ministry School unaccredited but it was
much more experiential and uh I can um
share a little bit more about that as we
land the plane maybe in like this final
season but that was kind of what
happened next wow there's the the thing
that stands out to me the most in that
story Sean is like there's so much hope
cuz you what you came out of and
everything that you experienced and then
again the fact that it it's not like a
one moment and everything changed and
all of a sudden like all the problems
are gone or anything like that but that
you started down that path and you
started to practice like just get into
things just try it out and like you're
encouraging people um who are listening
to do like just just start like getting
your um orientation around the things of
the Bible and start putting yourself in
better situations start focusing on
better things and then um that that real
experience with God's love is what like
that where that true transformation
happened but it doesn't mean that
everything is perfect after that right
so you've experienced a lot since that
moment and struggled with a lot and and
had a lot of those moments again of kind
of Rec coming to God and like okay let's
work through this and so for people who
are listening I think a lot of times we
feel like you know it has to be one
moment and Everything's changed I have
to have that like crazy experience but
really it's just about starting MH it's
just about starting on that path like
you said start going to a church check
it out start listening to those those
nudges those things that are like coming
up in your you know in your gut or your
heart your soul is what I would say it's
like those things that are starting to
prompt you and start taking action
towards that and and real like the
person you were that you were describing
to us as like a 20-year-old is so
radically different than who you are
today and I'm so grateful for who you
are today Sean that I am so grateful cuz
what you've gone through and what you've
done now with um think media and you
know everything you've been through has
changed my life know has changed life of
people who are part of our community as
well so I'm so grateful that you that
you did that and so I I really do hope
that like if nothing else is taken away
from this that somebody else like starts
that path as well um just knowing how
big of an impact that can have not only
on you but on other people as well so
I'm really grateful for that and I know
that there's a little bit more that
we're going to talk through yeah and so
I know this has already been a long
conversation but it is kind of fun to
get into these details I think um I we
talked about doing a follow-up episode
even on some of maybe the biblical
foundations that I think applied to
content creation um but yeah I think
probably the last season since we're
going sort of formation origin story is
then meeting my wife Sonia and now we're
married 18 years so I'm in church
volunteering the youth ministry Red
Robin waiting tables that's still the
the money maker I worked at Red opin for
10 years from 17 to 27 as we in
Marysville Washington there's State
Street it's a kind of a small town kind
of like a pass through town um
everything's changing in the whole
Pacific Northwest but you'd say it's a
little more Blue Collar especially back
then and but there was this this
Starbucks on 88th Street and that
Starbucks was like our spot it it's like
the coolest spot we would go there to
study the Bible get coffee whatever um
that's where we'd Jeff and David would
do all their meetings with their leaders
we'd cycle through they do like 30
minute increments and we' we were all
the interns volunteers whatever um and
so at Starbucks I would go in there all
the time when I was in what was called
Sumer nor northwest school of ministry
Arts Northwest and it started at 6:00
a.m. so we launched this Bible College
there was the first generation the first
year then I was in the second year class
and it started at 6 a.m. because it was
also for maybe working adults so all
ages could attend it and study the Bible
even more but also go through evangelism
discipleship old Testament New Testament
and practical mini Ministry courses and
so um because it started at 6:00 a.m. I
would try to get to Starbucks at 500 or
5:30 to get some coffee do a little bit
bit of homework read the Bible and Sonia
my now wife was a barista that would
always open Starbucks so she started to
see this guy coming in and like it's a
little bit weird like no one else is
there I'm coming in I crack my Bible on
a consistent basis and she she's like
what the heck now she's dating a guy so
she's focused on that relationship as
you should be but she's also kind of
noticing that like who's this guy and I
think also because her background
Seventh Day Adventist but at the time
she's in a sorority at the University of
Washington kind of in a little bit of
that same party culture um she's the
most wholesome sweet person so the
extremes of her partying are maybe
somewhat tame but she's in it she's
doing it you know she's noticing kind of
me we're sort of talking and we begin to
um eventually she breaks up with her
boyfriend and I'm going through all this
stuff of like how like okay I'm super
focused now eventually I I I early on as
I started interning I was struggling in
a relationship just meaning I mean
Christian values would be not sleeping
around or things like that or you know
kind of a sex before marriage would be
that traditional thing and so I'm trying
to kind of get out of that eventually I
do and once I do I'm now like it's Jesus
and then like whoever my wife will be
and I'm going to I'm straight and narrow
it's like this is what this is what's
happening but then it's also kind of
hard to figure out like how do you date
and we actually learned some stuff about
it was called the counterculture
approach to dating which was this whole
like conference we did and all this
stuff it was all right but it was kind
of toxic like it was actually it with
the beliefs and the views and at this
point once I went because I I'm
definitely extreme it's like if we were
going like Method Man and wuang I'm
going all the way if we're going like
Jesus and the Bible I'm going all the
way like so uh I I am like and I'm
trusting like Jeff and David who's
teaching this so there was like rules
and tenets about what you could do and
couldn't do what you could say and
couldn't say one of the biggest ones
being listen you cannot declare intent
so it like you should hang with girls
like in group settings get to know them
but but but do not declare intent
because as soon as you declare intent
feelings start now I understand that a
little toxic and weird though but like
uh but that was what they said so I was
like the letter of Jeff and David's law
is you cannot declare intent So
eventually Sonia breaks up with her
boyfriend I try to there's a few times
I'm trying to get the courage to ask her
out but I also am like troubled because
counterculture approached to Dating
Rules and I remember one day I wrote my
phone number on a Starbucks stir stick
and I was like I'm GNA give this to her
this is the day and I threw it away I I
gave up I saw her we talked and then I
and then I threw it away that do good oh
man and so I started though I kept
coming in I would go to Starbucks all
the time to like I would just get a
water if I was too caffeinated um just
to kind of see her and so she maybe is
also like is he like coming to see me or
is he just thirsty uh and so you know
eventually I find out that she's a
runner she's in running I had never been
into running in my life I had some gym
clothes and stuff but like I'd never
been into running but I got an
idea like wait a minute if she's in
running what if I went into 88
Starbucks in my gym closeth running
cloth and just just order coffee not
even say anything just kind of like a
subtle hint and sure enough I walk up
and she like she like look so like oh
hey Sean good to see you she's like wait
a minute are are you into running and I
was
like obviously I mean as you can see I
mean it's visible and so um she's like
oh wow we should go running sometime I'm
like you think so let's do it and uh
funny other side quest was I had this
horrible car this like Toyota box
um like wagon the Toyota wagon
1985 or something but my dad had a sick
WRX silver WRX like twin turbo like
amazing Subaru and so I I also was just
borrowing it all the time so she also
saw me coming in she was like dude this
this is a young Legend what is like a
young entrepreneur or something is he
rich like what and so she thought I
drove a WRX I'm a pro Runner yes fire
running and uh I remember she's like
yeah and I was like I'll pick you up and
I took her to the Arlington airport
which is kind of a natural Loop a
natural uh you know Loop you could run
on but I picked her up in the Volkswagen
and she didn't tell me Tell later but
she was like what happened I mean the
Toyota the Toyota wagon she was like
what what happened like this this date
started off way different and also it
was a date I mean it was just kind of
her and I but uh and I was also very
nervous like what if she's like super
athletic cuz I'm like I'm not even in
shape I can't keep up with her and so we
jogged for half a mile and then we just
walked which was cool cuz we talked a
lot and I'm super super grateful cuz
that was about the limit of my endurance
and so anyways we started to kind of
like have some touch points like that
but our relationship was very Rocky and
Incredibly TR um traumatic for her as
she looks back because what would happen
is I would drop insane amounts of hits
invite you running invite you this but
then I would like flip and be like very
standoffish out of my guilt and response
to like oh I think I broke a bunch of
countercultural Dating Rules um and so
it it was so bad and remember I'm just
trying to be a good student and like not
declare intent and I remember one night
we went to like Seattle with my friend
Spencer and there's like some other
girls there and she thought I was
flirting with them I probably was but
like we got back to Starbucks to drop
her off at her car and she was like you
know what I'm just so like confused like
if you can't say you like me I don't
know if I can handle this anymore and I
remember I sat in the car and my lips
were sealed I was actually in my mind
being like I'm not allowed to say I like
her cuz that's intent I mean so I was
trying to walk and so by God's grace
Sonia uh we made it this far I mean
because um and So eventually we got
married and obviously that was very um
transformational and and uh we started
to go to Bible school together and and
our Mar and marriage is very hard our
first we got married in 2005 marriage is
is difficult as many people know and
especially when you're lacking skills or
your example that you saw of her parents
our first two years of our marriage was
hell verifiably like we had Jeff and
Aaron the youth pastor and his wife uh
kind of taking us through marriage
counseling and whatnot and it was also
we were we were so busy too we were
interning waiting she had worked
multiple jobs and it wasn't wise we were
too busy we just were so involved in
Ministry trying to pay the bills we
bought a house right away eventually got
crushed in the big short bought a second
house got crushed in The Big Short um
and so there was just a lot of pressure
and a lot of things on those early days
and so it's amazing that we made it
through but maybe the last thing that I
also think about how powerful one of the
things that's maybe thinking about what
shaped me today that she has shaped me
and she's maybe a better person I think
marriage I know that marriage could be
very hard and empathy if maybe marriages
are broken apart but I think that's
that's also what should be inspected in
marriage like we plan so much invest so
much time in the day like the wedding
day when really that's by far not the
difficult part it's really now the
decade that follows and I I think people
shouldn't be surprised that it's hard
I've learned that marriage can really be
God's tool for shaping you into who
you're called to be it almost feels like
it feels like the opposite of that like
I feel like this is bringing the worst
out of me but one of the analogies I
heard is that when you're uh refining
gold when you're like melting gold down
like a gold ring if you put it in the
hot fire the temperature is as high as
possible that's what brings impurities
to the top of the gold so the impurities
can be uh pulled away the thing is those
impurities were always there but until
the fire got hot you didn't know and so
I definitely found that be helping me
become who I am today being in the local
church environment getting married to
Sonia and we got married super young we
got married at 21 dated for about a year
and a half or or knew each other for
maybe about a year and a half two years
I don't even know if you call it dating
cuz I couldn't intent for half of that
couldn't say you liked her so yeah
eventually got engaged and uh and and
she was a virgin when we got married too
which is incredible you know very
gracious of her and us coming together
but also I think the urgency in us
getting married was because of our
intern culture too we're like young you
know whatever and I mean sorry to be so
we we you know we wanted to be together
so we and interesting though about that
culture all our friends got married
super young everybody was like 18 19 22
and
and whether good or bad God works
through all things some of those
marriages haven't last and what whatnot
and I look back in hindsight I really
see God's hand and everything but it
speaks to the environment you're in the
culture you're in that happened to be
the culture male brains don't even fully
stop developing until 25 you don't even
know who you are you're still trying to
figure out who you are so you know take
it for what it is that was our story but
I think the one other thing as far as
like again or story and one of the most
powerful things I learned is the
proximity
principle and this maybe goes all the
way back to being in bad party
environments but it also speaks to being
in good environments us together in this
local church context serving I think the
best form of education is Hands-On it's
not actually it's not what I think like
statistically five 10% of people can
effectively learn just by studying
material there's you get you get about
another 20% that can effectively learn
and Implement what they can kind of
observe but it's really about 70 75%
kinesthetic learning that actually
transforms you which means handson so us
being in Ministry interning printing
Flyers
Photoshop um doing events trying to
figure out how to buy cheap lighting at
at uh you know some light shop in
Seattle and make it cool on no budget
learning I say it's never about your
resources it's about your
resourcefulness we were learning that
real time this was the C outdated camera
gear how do we how do we make the
sanctuary cool at the church how do we
start using social media and then having
a a reason to use social media started a
YouTube channel for the church in 2007
two years after YouTube started started
a Twitter account and a Facebook page
and so that was the Hands-On context was
how do we use social media and YouTube
to grow a church to market the church to
internally communicate messages and then
trying to figure out being married and
then also being immersed in um
discipleship and not just biblical
discipleship but also leadership
training those foundations without a
doubt we wouldn't be here think media
wise not just the YouTube stuff that was
there too but I think also the
leadership stff we're a team of 30
people trying to figure all that kind of
stuff out so for what it's worth one of
the biggest things I've learned is that
when some if you have a desire to do
something if you're in a circumstance
where you can learn from home and do an
online course and read books that's good
and if you can also get more immersed
where you're maybe in a private
Community or you have some kind of an
online group or Discord or Facebook
group that's better but if you can
actually get Hands-On which you could
choose to get Hands-On at home with your
own content but I I think that um maybe
working for interning or trying to get
in proximity with people doing the thing
that you want to do is very underrated
Robert kosaki and Rich Dad Poor Dad says
that he goes one of the smartest things
you could do is go intern go intern or
go work for somebody or a company doing
the thing that you want to do I think in
the creater economy right now um there
is so I I believe anybody can go
full-time on YouTube it doesn't
necessarily mean you're going to be the
personality that's full-time on YouTube
you may do it with a faceless Channel
you might be the personal brand but you
also might be a videographer or work as
a freelancer or I mean I would argue
think media we're all full-time
YouTubers we all work 40 hours a week if
we're full-time we just have different
roles and we're all in the Creator
economy um so the power maybe there's
that's what has been so transformative
to me when I got around ambitious
creative people that you know like Jeff
who's been one of the biggest influences
again just came to my 40th birthday
party one of the Jeff Moors massive
honor and respect and gratitude to that
guy Church planner in Oceanside
California at Rhythm church if you're in
Oceanside or ever in the area you got to
check it out awesome uh Jeff and Aaron
incredible guy um his influence in my
life and people like him shifting my
thinking learning skills seeing that he
always saw the possibilities um I
probably 99% of the things I've ever uh
said are borrowed AKA stolen from really
smart people so I'm like you know rise
and grind it's new day of New
Opportunities and new possibilities Jeff
was probably one of the first people who
helped me be a possibility thinker I I I
could always complain I could always see
what's I could see a problem with every
opportunity he might say what if we did
this to impact more youth in our in our
city what if we and i' be like sounds
like it's going to be work dude it
sounds like it's GNA I could always
complain but he helped me to see like
what if we looked at the possibilities
what's possible man what if we thought a
little bit how could we do that and so
many other influences in my life so man
the people you get around the
environment you plant yourself in and
there is something about sometimes doing
it when you feel it and sometimes doing
it when you don't feel like I feel like
like for example planting in church like
I'm going to go to church when I feel
like it I think that's the wrong
mentality it's like no whether I feel
like it or I'm going to read my Bible
when I feel like it no like I read I I
I'm going to do certain habits and
practices in my life whether I feel it
or not and those end up resulting I'm
going to be in
relationships I'm only going to be in
the relationship if we never disagree
get offended or have conflict well
that's what a lot of people do they run
as soon as things get hard or as soon as
like their feelings no I think that um
there's something about having
convictions and values and knowing the
local church changed my life I believe
the local church the hope of the World
Christian relationships good
relationships being how can you get
around other leaders and so the
proximity principle Ken Coleman wrote B
on the proximity principle there's you
can apply it even if you feel like you
can't move or change or sift your
circumstances there so many situations
where that can apply but we've covered a
lot those are some of the foundational
things and then um you know here we are
today think media and I feel like we're
just getting started God yes absolutely
and what a journey you have gone through
to get us to where we are today and I
just see there's there's Grace there's
grace through that entire story and
there's Grace for all of our stories um
through all those ups and downs all the
craziness and I'm sure there are people
are listening that's like oh Sean that
story is tame like your past that's
nothing compared to mine and there's
Grace for it there's Grace for every
circumstance every person um who's gone
through similar things or worse things
than what you've gone through and um I
really do want to like take the
opportunity at the end of the Shonda
maybe pray for people are listening this
right now who really need that Grace who
really need that hope and the idea that
there is something better in
2024 um I know you you said that there's
there is possibility for 2024 to be the
best year ever but we've got to get some
things in line MH and so I really do
think that we teach a lot of YouTube
tips we teach people how to get their
YouTube channel in line how to get their
business strategy but what is the core
of all of it the core of all of it I
believe is that you've got to have
yourself right with God you've got to
have your you got to work on your heart
and on your spiritual life and so um
again Sean maybe you could close us out
by just praying through um for people
that are listening to this right now who
really do need that in this new year
yeah I would love to and uh just so
grateful for everybody listening and I
know I we've never done this before on
the podcast but this whole podcast is a
wild ride of totally different so yeah
and just sending massive love and
respect to our community I know we have
different beliefs and and um different
background but man if you made it this
far um and I would love to to pray for
our entire Community that's a great idea
um and I really do believe that uh God
can show up in your life this year and
do something amazing so absolutely so
yeah let's pray okay so uh so God we
just come to you today God and I thank
you so much for just the opportunity to
share some stories to share about um a
little bit of my history and to see your
faithful hand and Grace throughout all
of the years God I thank you so much for
Melissa God I thank you for the think
media team and everybody that works on
um this podcast and makes this happen um
and I thank you for this community no
matter where people are in the world
listening to this I'm so grateful for
every individual that's been touched by
this podcast and um Holy Spirit I pray
that you would encounter and encourage
each and every person listening to this
God I pray that right now people would
have an encounter even with your love
that maybe they're far from you and at
one time we're following you God I pray
that their heart would just be softened
and they would feel drawn back to you in
Jesus name and I pray for those that
maybe maybe they uh have no background
in religion or anything God that you
would just begin to work even in their
life and that you would reveal yourself
self to them God I thank you that you
our creator that you know what's best
for us um God that you designed us and
knit each and every one of us together
in our mother's womb that each and every
person on this planet matters to you and
God I pray for whatever influence this
podcast has that those listening to it
would have their best year ever um would
not just flourish in business and on
YouTube but most of all would flourish
spiritually and would be able to open
their Bibles or get a Bible began to
study even as as there's maybe questions
and uncertainty about what the future
holds um God I just pray a stirring of
people's Faith to seek after you
trusting that you said when we seek you
we'll find you when we seek you with all
our heart that maybe they know that
other things they've sought after like I
did just don't satisfy um and that we
were ultimately created to be in
relationship with you not some religion
where we just are following rules but
where we actually are walking with you
and um in Jesus name we just commit all
these things to you commit the future of
this podcast to you and uh this
community and this movement and God
we're so humbled and grateful for all
you've done in our lives and what you'll
continue to do in Jesus name amen thank
you Sean um there's so much more that we
could talk about on these top topics as
well and I know that um it's on your
heart to continue sharing just more
about your story I would love to get
into I think like the next season of
your life really is like the start of
think media and those kind of Origins so
um I definitely want to talk about that
on a future episode as well and go
through um what it was like really
starting think media what that
experience was like on a more um you
know the more detailed level and so I'm
sure that that can be of a lot of value
to the people who are listening as well
but for now I think we'll wrap up this
episode and I just if you're still
listening thank you for being here with
us thank you for being a part of the um
the story and the journey and like you
said Sean really looking forward to what
is next for think media and uh make sure
that you are subscribed to the podcast
so you can hear these future
conversations that are coming up and
we'll see you on the next one